well I think I made a transition the
last five years or so and before I would
have just call myself a serial
entrepreneur now I think I'm a serial
entrepreneur that's going to forever do
do-gooder things so you know I'm that's
what gets I'm very excited by change and
by building something for nothing and at
this point what what on top of that I'm
really I want to do good I think there's
a lot of suffering in the world and I'd
like to see what I can do to reduce it
the transition okay well so I my cousin
I built this great company around 60
people we started 95 pre Netscape so
very early i'm just a great work
programming project manager and the sort
of stuff and it was there were a lot of
acquisitions going on at that point and
we got a lot of interest and so where we
were we ended up selling to a new york
company and i sort of finagled my way
here via running an office for them for
a little bit in boston and then with the
promised i'd be allowed to come and work
out of the new york office because I was
very attracted to to New York so that's
sort of how I got here and after a while
I just it wasn't the right fit for me
with the company and I think I was
really ready for something something new
so I tried a couple of things and really
got my first d I just didn't go so well
and which I think was really great
because I finally it sort of let off a
lot of pressure and I think it also
folks me that first thing wasn't
particularly positive and it's more of a
benign project internet-based thing so
they actually got me focused on you know
I really want to do something that
really matters to me and really isn't in
sync with my values and i think i was
really affected by reading and I
click I think books are really under
their power is underestimated I think
something about you pick it up if you
get you have to remember where you're at
what the whole overall concept is you
get into it and you provide energy to
it's not just sort of fed to you until
you really then you put it down and you
pick it up and you put it down it's
hundreds of pages often and it goes over
the same staff in various ways and so it
sinks in in a way that I think a lot of
things don't so books are really
powerful I think that really helps a lot
of my reading on evolution and on green
just got me really and just on sort of
social entrepreneurship this sort of
stuff got me very just right turn on i
was very excited about the whole
prospect feeling it the way it started I
just sort of said like why what's
happening here like why isn't green
mainstream like it seemed to me that a
lot of people really cared about it but
it just hadn't hadn't made that move so
why was that and so I just started
looking at myself and trying to try to
just answer that question so the what I
thought was well first of all to me
aesthetics matter I'm a shallow person
and so I care about not that you can
tell I care about how I get my hair cut
and I care about the clothes that I wear
and I care about what my apartments like
and if I drove a car I would care about
that and so all these things like I wish
they didn't matter to me I wish I didn't
care but they do and so one of the one
of the issues the first one I sort of
highlighted was just that the hippies
had had really owned this area for 30 40
years they were the real backbone
clearly I come from there and so I love
the hippies but I really felt like for
the for the they are a very small
segment of the market and the rest of
the market 95% plus of the people it
just wasn't so appealing to them so the
hippies have done a great job of selling
marketing to that subsec sub-segments
and are very green and they're sort of
that whole markets soul too so I figured
if it was to going to go larger then it
really need to become more modern and
contemporary and and and have an
aesthetic that would appeal to much more
of the population so that was sort of
the first one the second problem i saw
was that I'm a busy guy and I live in
New York and I work very hard and so I'm
running from thing to thing and on the
weekends if I'm able to get any time off
you know I want to want to relax and see
my friends and do this sort of stuff so
real challenge at that point was it
really wasn't convenient so convenience
is the real killer and I think you
really need to make it easy so if I
needed to find that pair of organic
cotton pants or low v OC paints or
figure out you know posted by a hybrid
car or something these are activities
that would take hours and hours and so
ultimately they just wouldn't end up
happening or wouldn't end up happening
enough so the second problem that I saw
was just one of convenience we really
needed to make it convenient
the third was a lot of environmentalism
to that point had been about no had been
about the sky is falling had been about
inspired by fear and I actually think
that's we need a whole bunch of
approaches to this problem and that
approach is actually really important
it's important for you to understand the
gravity of the situation and that there
are major issues and all that's very
important but I think there are also
people who are looking for great so what
next how do we move how to move forward
and they're looking for yes that are
looking for inspired by hope and I think
I'm one of those people and so what I
figured was if one could create a site
that would aggregate all this modern
green sort of different aesthetic that
was starting to appear on a global basis
in one place make it very convenient for
people such that they could not spend a
ton of time and still no their lives in
the green direction and just make it
really positive and solutions oriented
that it would appeal to a market and it
would really help green go mainstream so
that was the basic thinking and so I in
94 94 in 2004 really got together and
launched p.m.
you